un personnel hospitalier déborder un
congé maternité cours et des femmes qui
travaillent autant de raisons qui freine
la mise au sein des bambins et même si
la france reste à la traîne certaines
femmes vont jusqu'au bout de leur désir
d'alerter et assument leur choix comme
c'est maman rencontrée lors d'une
réunion à versailles c'était familial à
la base dans toute ma famille à l'été et
puis après j'ai compris que c'était plus
simple pour le lever et puis plus
naturel ça lui donnait tout et puis bon
en tant que jeune je pense qu'on est
toutes les trois là on se connaît tous
en fait il ya quand même un aspect
budget c'est bête mais ça fait réfléchir
je me voyais pas faire autrement fait
enfin c'était là dans la continuité de
la grossesse
et voilà pour créer du lien avec ma
fille pour je sais pas france est elle
est naturelle naturelle mais pas aussi
simple que ça les études démontrent que
les femmes qui font le choix de
l'allaitement ont pour la plupart fait
des études supérieures et sont
indépendantes difficile alors de
concilier réussite professionnelle et
vie de famille pourtant certaines y
parviennent elles seront capables de
dire mais moi ça me plaît et je veux le
beurre et l'argent du beurre c'est à
dire je veux continuer mon métier
reprendre
mon travail continuel était mon enfant
et elle ne se laisse pas abattre par
exemple à la reprise du travail afin
d'être mieux informés les futures mamans
se tourner vers des associations
spécialisées ou écoute et échanges
d'expériences dé rassure dans
l'agglomération des animations et des
rencontres sont proposées autour de ce
thème du 15 au 21 octobre